[Musique]
alger la blanche avec ces quartiers
populaires qui surplombe la mer et son
célèbre monument aux martyrs
la capitale compte un nouvel élément
dans son paysage
son minaret fait 265 mètres de haut
la salle de prière peut accueillir 120
mille fidèles
cette nouvelle mosquée est la troisième
plus grande au monde et la coûté près de
3 milliards de dollars entièrement payés
par l'état algérien le symbole de
grandeur légué par le régime du
président abdelaziz bouteflika
juste avant son départ forcé le mode de
vie ou dix ans le confort le confort en
général il a progressé à nager les gens
vivent mieux aujourd'hui que 1960 70 80
l'algérie arrive au 4e rang des plus
riches pays d'afrique infrastructures
développées éducation et santé gratuits
logement et aliments subventionner tout
ça grâce au pétrole
depuis l'année 2000 quand le baril a
commencé à augmenter mais quand il
atteint 30 $ par exemple en appelant
l'algérie à rembourser ses dettes elle
n'a plus de dette internationale qui a
peut-être avec ce surplus de recettes
il ya beaucoup d'investissement
[Musique]
le géant sonatrach contrôler tout le
secteur des hydrocarbures du pays
c'est la plus grande compagnie
pétrolière en afrique avec ses filiales
en algérie d ailleurs dans le monde
cette société d'état emploie près de 200
mille personnes
son principal centre d'activité se situe
au centre du pays dans la région de
ouargla
c'est là que vit tahar belabès un ex
employés de sonatrach et militant
syndical maintenant au chômage
notre revendication c'est que cette
société d'état c'est comme une
entreprise coloniale une société privée
contrôlée par une clique de
fonctionnaires et de politiciens nous
n'avons pas été autorisés à nous rendre
à ouargla
nous avons demandé à tahar belabès de
nous retrouver à alger
[Musique]
dans le sud algérien il ya deux
catégories d'entreprises
d'abord des multinationales associé à
sonatrach qui ne se soucient pas du
droit local et des sous traitants locaux
dirigés par d'anciens militaires haut
gradés qui se comportent comme de vrais
esclavagiste tahar belabès a été
congédié après avoir organisé des
manifestations réclamant des emplois
pour les chômeurs de sa région jusqu'à
2000 mois sa compagnie a porté plainte
contre moi parce que je faisais de
l'obstruction avec des jeunes
il a été emprisonné à quelques reprises
son passeport lui a été retiré pendant
la majeure partie du règne de bouteflika
et pourtant ils continuent à manifester
et souvenirs d'arrêter à n'importe quel
moment
[Applaudissements]
le pays est aujourd'hui sans dessus
dessous l'insatisfaction générale ne
faiblit pas le taux de chômage
algérienne est actuellement de 12 %
plus alarmant chez les jeunes de moins
de 25 ans qui forment près de la moitié
de la population
il touche une personne sur trois chez
les diplômés universitaires une personne
sur quatre est sans emploi qu'il y avait
eu d'abord une bonne gestion de la rente
pétrolière réinvestis pour créer
l'emploi la richesse on avait de quoi
faire devenir l'algérie pratiquement
pays autosuffisant à tous les niveaux
aujourd'hui on aurait un degré de
développement extraordinaire
abdelmajid attar a été brièvement
ministre sous le président bouteflika et
pdg de la puissante sonatrach de 1997 à
2000 ils dénoncent le manque de vision
du régime au pouvoir à structure de
l'emploi
tenez vous bien mais aussi la corruption
omniprésente dans le pays
le problème c'est que non seulement la
corruption elle a permis à la ouvert les
caisses à des gens qui en ont profité
mais elle a empêché en même temps par
mauvaise gouvernance la mise en oeuvre
d'autres activités le développement
d'une industrie le développement des
services interactifs tard voilà menacé
de mort par un ex miné
halim fadal dirige une association parmi
plusieurs qui dénoncent la corruption en
algérie on peut aller jusqu'à 40% défend
qui sont dilapidés il n'est pas le seul
à le dire la culture du pouls de vin est
présente à tous les niveaux
s'il ya des passations de marchés il y a
des pots-de-vin si les recrutements il y
à des pots de vin chaque acte il est
devenu une transaction qui entachez bacs
de collecte
le tourisme est un exemple éloquent des
effets néfastes de la corruption sur
l'économie du pays
contrairement à ses voisins côtier du
maroc et de la tunisie l'algérie n'a pas
choisi de développer cette industrie
la corruption a pris une ampleur
phénoménale
la première des choses ont un projet en
tête qui sait qu'on connaît dans ce
secteur ce n'est pas vos dossiers qu'on
juge jean c'est la personne qui vous
êtes et votre relationnel et l'argent
que vous pouvez avancer cette agente de
voyage ajoute que la très lourde
bureaucratie et les déficiences du
système bancaire algérien parvient à
décourager les promoteurs les plus
motivés
c'est aberrant de devoir attendre un an
et demi avant d'ouvrir un restaurant
sauf si vous connaissez quelqu'un parce
que bien sûr si vous connaissez
quelqu'un vous blesser voilà une petite
enveloppe
ça va aller bien plus vite faut des lois
strictes pour une bonne gouvernance faut
que chacun sache ce à quoi il a droit
ce à quoi il n'a pas droit
l'avenir économique de l'algérie reste à
écrire
l'exercice est en cours les militants
pour le progrès social comme tahar
belabès constatent que leur cause est
maintenant porté par un vaste mouvement
populaire qui réclame au préalable le
départ de la classe politique au pouvoir
[Musique]
sylvain voit bien la difficulté pour
l'algérie de diversifier son économie
alors on en est où la situation
financière du pays en est où la
situation financière du pays est très
très mauvaise parce que ses revenus
baissent dernières années parce que
depuis la chute des prix du pétrole des
prix mondiaux
évidemment les revenus baissent
énormément et comme c'est un pays qui
dépend presque exclusivement du pétrole
et ses revenus n'arrive plus à couvrir
les dépenses importantes sociale qui
existait en algérie depuis toujours
donc là on se dirige vers vraiment un
mur de 6 5 à 6 ans on aura épuisé les
réserves des réserves financières
importantes qui avaient constitué
l'algérie mais qui fondent comme neige
au soleil depuis les quatre ou cinq
dernières années à cause de cette chute
du prix donc on en est là à une petite
réserve qu'il n'y arrivera pas à
permettre au pays de survivre à ce
rythme là il les réserves
d'hydrocarbures elle est ce qu'elles
sont viables à long terme ou pas alors
les réserves de pétrole diminue et
l'extraction diminue aussi parce qu'on
appuie des techniques pour aller le
chercher là où il se trouve il plus loin
par contre on note d'énormes réserves de
gaz de schiste un gros potentiel
économique à développer
sauf qu'on n'a pas les techniques on n'a
pas l'expertisé pour le faire le besoin
partenaires internationaux pour le faire
mais on n'arrive pas à les convaincre à
cause de situation qui est très instable
dans le pays pour le moment donc on
s'entend disposition aussi sociale il y
à des oppositions sociales effectivement
qui n'aide pas donc on se retrouve dans
une situation un peu comme au venezuela
où on a abusé de la ressource on n'a pas
planifié
on n'a pas diversifié actuellement le
pas de solution économique à moyen terme
pour sauver l'algérie de cette
malédiction de l'or noir voilà un
exemple comme s'ils s'y vend au prix